yes thank you
please
um
Ursula it's always such a pleasure to
sit down with you obviously a great
pleasure to be with the president of the
European commission
um again I wanted to thank you for the
incredible visit to Canada just a couple
of months ago the opportunity to go see
was critical minerals or speak to
Parliament there was uh just a
tremendous appreciation not just of you
but of the European Union's engagement
with Canada obviously we're here for uh
for uh conversations about the state of
the world about how we're going to move
forward on addressing some of the big
Global crises in a way that works
together both on the economic side on
the climate side on the humanitarian
side on the international diplomacy side
it's always a pleasure to be working
with you uh
foreign
thank you very much for having this
bilateral meeting here today after
indeed it's a couple of weeks time ago
that you hosted me in Canada and in
about two weeks we're gonna meet again
Hiroshima and this only proves that
you're one of our most trusted partners
and the corporation is excellent and we
need a strong Partners to tackle all the
issues that the world brings along we
will discuss the fight against climate
change but certainly also the evolution
in the indo-pacific
topics that we have on the agenda for G7
so a pleasure to be here with you today
thank you